do a couple of announcements and then
have a quick guest lecture from Mort
Sood Hoff just because it was
irresistible in terms of more it's just
having done a project that kind of
bridges us from the VSM unit into the
big themes that I tried to introduce
last time around send them an analysis
and why you would want to do it and
tasks that are adjacent to it but first
just a couple of quick announcements
first it's really exciting to see the
bake-off submissions coming in I've been
checking them periodically throughout
the day I'm not going to reveal anything
about the scores because we want to
reproduce everything but I will say that
I myself I was pretty proud of my system
I thought I was doing pretty well and
it's pretty clear actually that I would
have gotten about 30th place some people
have really done better than I did
Blaney will have a fuller report after
we've done some reproductions next week
the other announcements I wanted to make
is like I'm my bias for this course is
definitely that you all come up with
your own projects I think that's more
exciting but when people write in with
project ideas that you might you know
for ongoing things that you might want
to join I can't say no because some of
those things are really exciting as well
and I wanted to just mention two today
so this first one this is from the
people at grid space which is an area
startup that does a lot of
speech-to-text work they have lots of
Stanford connections as well some of you
might have encountered them they're
developing some new data sets that are
going to be kind of quasi public not
protected data so it's pretty free use
and they're around dialogues and at
least part of those are people
interacting with artificial agents so if
you're interested in that project they
have this Google form that you could
fill out and then I think they'll get in
touch with you about sharing the data
and so forth and actually this is
exciting because they're still in the
process of getting feedback from people
potentially you about what kind of
labels they should get and how they
should design the data set so this is a
chance to kind of get in early the other
thing I would say is that I attached a
bunch of sample files which they sent me
and the automated dialogue mp4 is is
hilarious as advertised here so check
that out and then the other one is from
Vienna Chaudhary who has done this in
the past he's got a project ongoing that
some students work with successfully in
the winter for the cs2 to 4n and this is
nicely time because the centerpiece of
this is relation extraction using
distance supervision which is our topic
for next week so you potentially get a
nice confluence of the work we'll be
doing and a project that you might
develop with VNA so again I've provided
his contact info and I think you should
feel free to write to him okay and then
before we dive back into the SST let me
invite Moritz to come up as I said this
was just a great opportunity because
right now and the topics are nicely
aligned with both things that we've done
so far right so as we're diving into the
next unit many many of you are already
starting on your projects or at least
thinking about it I want to take five
minutes to just do a little aggression
into politics and also make make my case
that you should not forget about
anything that we've learned in the last
two weeks because it's extraordinarily
useful for whatever you're going to be
doing moving forward and to prove that
point let's talk about politics so
five-minute digression politics
specifically political polling so I do
some work with a democratic political
polling company and what I learned about
the space which is kind of interesting
is the political polling is actually
really bad right now most of it still
happens on the phone and you get these
like really kind of structured questions
like do you care more about balancing
the budget or income tax choose a or b
and so the the actual like information
that polish ins politicians get back is
very sterile and it's like highly issues
based but what they really want to know
is they really want to know like as a
voter who are you voting for and why
what's driving your decision how are you
thinking about candidates how are you
thinking about the election like what
messages are resonate
with you what's top of mind for you they
want to get into this lot more about
attitudes perceptions opinions and see
the parallels the sentiment are clear
where it if we know that Beto O'Rourke
is you know has 32 percent of the vote
and Elizabeth Warren has 18 is the same
as knowing that one product has a
five-point you know five star rating the
other has a 4.5 the question is why
what's the difference between those two
why why do some experiences resonate
more than others why are some why do
some things receive more support than
others and so imagine that you're
building an analyst system and it's
needs to answer these questions what our
voters looking for in a candidate why
are this why are they supporting their
stated choice for the election and for
this data set we're going to be looking
at three quick questions from a survey
they were asked what qualities do you
look for in a president in a candidate
for US Congress or Senate or for
somebody for state or local government
and we also have for each respondent the
party identification so baseline you
have a few thousand responses of people
basically talking about what is how are
they framing this election who are they
supporting and why and we want to start
to understand okay how can we give
politicians real kind of richer feedback
on what's driving these decisions and so
I wanted to show you a notebook but I
couldn't get my own computer connected
but the only reason I wanted to show you
notebook is because this is literally
the only code in that notebook just
using our wonderful VSM code I took I
built my own like word by word matrix
but that's everybody knows that do that
you call these two lines and suddenly
all the rest of the exploration
basically is just based off of these two
lines of code so I think it does a nice
job of showing how quickly you can get
started with a totally new and unknown
data set so what I wanted to just do
very quickly is look at some of these
teesta plots so let's say that we're
interested in understanding okay
do Democrats and Republicans make
decisions differently based off of for
for the election so this is obviously
you can kind of just see there's some
colors here so I've wait I've colored
the terms based off of whether they're
more associated with Democrats or
Republicans so
Green is independent red is Republican
that's kind of up here how do I
I'm not Chris and more it's red is up
here blue is more down here and if you
actually zoom into it there's a there's
a couple of nice things that happen I've
already annotated it just for clarity
here you can see that on the Republican
side people are talking a lot about
issues so the words that you can't
really read up there are words like
defense fiscal you know words like
Constitution these are all about
conservative values immigration policies
and values but if you look at to where
the clusters are more dominated by blue
here you get things like collaborative
cooperative composed articulate
charismatic well-spoken these are all
descriptions of personal characteristics
these are descriptions of somebody that
probably doesn't match how these people
are thinking about Trump and so you can
see already kind of a clear split
between how the Democrats are thinking
about candidates in the election and how
Republicans are we can also look at this
again taking advantage of that structure
we had in the data set which was we also
know what office they're talking about
we can look at the same thing this time
we're coloring the colors the words
based on whether it's more likely to be
in a review or in a comment about
presidential local or congressional
elections and as you would expect
there's ton here the personal qualities
this blue this dark blue that's all
presidential so personal qualities like
temperament being quick being unifying
being a negotiator being classy those
are all super important for president
but if you look more at the the area
over here where it's the other colors
for local elections
whoops sorry Chris you can see that it's
a lot more about issues we have
advocates accessible as health care
affordable housing these are much more
than bread and butter of like I have
local policies that I care about that
need to get done I'm going to comment
here great work Moritz oh wow thanks
Chris and the final thing I want to show
so ok so this has been this was like how
long did it take me to do this all I
needed was to take the original data and
then call 2 lines of this code and then
another visualization line
and I feel like we're already starting
to get a sense for how we would tackle
this problem so we're building a an NLU
system to answer the question what are
candidates what our voters looking for
and why are they supporting candidate X
over Y so I think one thing we know is
we have to be sensitive to whether
they're talking about issues or personal
characteristics that seems to be kind of
a cleavage in our data and the other
thing that we might want to understand
is like okay we want to understand
personal qualities more and how those
which qualities are resonating more with
other people so maybe we dig deeper and
try to find sub clusters of you know
this is about decency and humanity and
fairness but this is about being
well-spoken
and so this is this would be a first
step you're you're diving into a new
unknown data set you want to know what
is in it how do I actually solve those
higher-level
another--you problems I want to solve
the code that we've all explored so far
in the first unit is your best first
stop and even for I got paid to do this
by the way even for like in industry
this sort of code is it's not just
starter code it can give you a great
handle on on a data set on a problem and
so as you embark on this next unit and
your projects I encourage you never to
forget the the humble vector space
models and know also that domains like
politics like customer understanding and
experience like employee under
experience all of these domains need NLU
people they do not have it figured out
so it's up to all of us to help them and
do exciting new things for our projects
Thanks oh yeah any questions yeah you
guys are convinced yeah so the question
here is somebody answered a survey do we
even care about the data that comes back
do we do we trust it because it do we
think it means anything to us so the
deeper question there is we actually
have you know if in in in the actual
application of this analysis we have
data on turnout and previous support of
candidates and so there are things that
we can verify about like
yeah these people vote but I think the
broader question is when people are
telling you about their experience
should you care does it matter and I'm
gonna say I'm gonna make the claim that
whenever people are being emotional and
expressing opinions you should care
because they have taken like they did
not need to fill out these surveys or
offer these reviews and so there's my my
first bias as always there's something
of value here they had some reason for
telling us this and in aggregate if a
million people tell you something you
can learn something from it so I'm
always optimistic I guess to the answer
that question I think I mean one thing
that is true overall is in politics for
presidential elections in America style
matters so there's always gonna be some
of that entering but I think definitely
like it also speaks to kind of in the
age of Trump things are things are
different and like the word orange
showed a lot showed up a lot on this
data set you would not expect that to
ever be like a relevant thing to say in
a presidential survey otherwise so I
think like but that also speaks to how
like when I applied glove to the same
data it failed like it didn't because
the this delay the words people were
using in this context just means
something a lot more specific than in
all of the English language so there's
also kind of PMI coming back to the
rescue one glove failed okay let's dive
back into the sentiment stuff hmm and
just to recap what we did last time was
I set the stage I talked about sentiment
as a general problem in NL you and I
tried to make the case that it's a very
interesting problem even if at first
blush it might look kind of simple and
then I gave you some general tips show
you some evidence that it's worth
thinking about pre-processing your data
how you do that thoughtfully and so
forth
I introduced the Stanford sentiment
treebank that's up here and highlighted
some of its unique properties as a
dataset in general and certainly for
sentiment and then we spent a bunch of
time walking through the basics of SSTP
and i'm going to show you one screen
from that that kind of summarizes that
whole unit the reason that's important
is that's what you want to work with
productively as you're doing your
homework too and bake-off two and in
fact I'm going to try to get through
this material at a leisurely pace but
we'll keep our keep moving forward so
that we can have some class time today
to make sure that you guys are all set
up and working productively with it and
a bunch of the team is available in the
classroom and then did a post on Piazza
in case your remote and want to just log
in and chat with someone about how
things are working or maybe take a step
back from where we have and think about
regular supervised learning the kind of
stuff that I'm sort of taking for
granted in this course but I think the
team is happy to fill in any gaps that
you might have but the point is since
the time window is tight we want you to
get good with the code by the end of the
day today and we're available for that
this slide here kind of summarizes the
entire framework and in fact what I'm
showing here is kind of four simple
linear methods which we're going to
explore first but exactly this same
framework works for all the deep
learning models that we'll discuss and
it's meant to be flexible and modular in
a way that will let you run a lot of
experiments without making a lot of
mistakes and the the long and short of
it is you know set yourself up to point
to the data distribution your feature
functions here I've called it Phi shadow
is operate on trees and return
dictionaries let's assume they're I'll
count dictionaries you should also have
these model wrappers which taken a
supervised data set and XY pair fit a
model and return that fitted model and
then all you have to do to run an
experiment is call SST experiment
pointing at your data distribution with
that feature function and that model
wrapper and that's it
and already from here you can see that
there's lots of space to explore if I
wanted to try naivebayes or a support
vector machine I would just write a
different model wrapper if I wanted to
explore different feature functions I
would just write new functions of trees
and that would be very quick in terms of
evaluating and by default this is going
to evaluate on random train test splits
that are drawn from the training data
and you could periodically test against
the dev set to see how well you're doing
in reality that's the rhythm that I'm
imagining and I gave you a quick peek
under the hood at how this code is
designed I would encourage you to look
yourselves and find out even more about
how this is working but it's kind of all
based around these dict vectorizer x'
which i think helped us avoid a lot of
common coding mistakes when building
feature representations of data that's
the quick recap are there any questions
or comments about it before I dive into
this new stuff any concerns that might
have emerged over the last couple of
days all right
let's dive in we have budgeted some time
later in the term when you guys are in
the thick of your projects to talk a lot
about methods and metrics and we're
going to return to the two themes that
I'm going to introduce now in that
context and kind of talk about them even
with a little bit of philosophy behind
them but I want to introduce them now
because I think that both of these can
make you a better experimenter right
from the start those two things are kind
of hyper parameter exploration and
classifier comparison so let's start
first hyper parameter here I've called
it hyper parameter search and I want to
give you the rationale for it
so I'll just walk through this argument
for some terminology the parameters of a
model are those whose values are learned
as part of optimizing the model itself
those are sometimes called weights right
and that's mainly what we think of when
we think of machine learning is that
like from data our model has a capacity
to set all these parameters in a way
that's effective for new data
I'd say equally important are what are
called the hyper parameters of the model
these are any settings of the model that
are outside of the core
optimization process and some examples
are like in glove or LSA you have the
dimensionality of the representation
that you're going to learn or for it for
glove you have the learning rate for
glove you have x max as part of the
weighting function in alpha which is
also a pre-processing step essentially
that does something to your count matrix
neither of those values is learned as
part of glove but they're super
important in terms of what you learned
and also regularization terms hidden
dimensionalities learning rates
activation functions you can even go so
far as to say like the optimization
method itself the algorithm that you use
is the hyper parameter to your model
there's no end of these things
essentially if you go on to scikit-learn
and just look like in the linear model
package at things like logistic
regression or if you look at the support
vector machines in there or the naive
Bayes models they have dozens of things
that are hyper parameters and you can
see them codified in code because it
says like here all the keyword arguments
they have some defaults but that's just
one of the many values that you could
explore for each one of those things
this is crucial because to build a
persuasive argument you need to be
thoughtful about your hyper parameters
and the rationale there is what I've
said here every model that you evaluate
really needs to be put in the best
possible light and the right to round
that out otherwise right in a kind of
antagonistic situation you could appear
to have evidence that your model your
favored model is better than some other
one just by strategically picking hyper
parameters that favored yours over
another one right pick really good
settings for your model and ones that
you know are kind of degenerate for the
other one and then you say look my model
is better that's a problem hyper
parameter search is all about kind of
making sure that you don't have the
opportunity to do that opportunistic
selection and the other way to think
about this is that in science there is a
kind of antagonistic dynamic that
happens and I think it happens primarily
in the service of making sure we make
progress which is that you submit your
work somewhere
and some referee is now evaluating it
and the default mode for that referee is
to think does this person really have
results right can I trust what this
person is saying and from their
perspective they might think well
they've only shown me two settings how
do I know that they didn't pick those
settings in a way that would rig the
game in their favor and what that
referee is really looking for is
evidence from you that you have done
what I've described in three here which
is put every model that you evaluate in
the best possible light given the data
that you have and what that really
implies then is that when you evaluate
these two models you do quite extensive
hyper parameter search and you describe
not only the space that you explored and
that but then also report some
statistics about how those models
performed certainly the best performing
model but maybe other information about
average performance and so forth and
once you've done that if your model wins
we have a lot more confidence and your
referee is going to feel less
antagonistic because they can feel like
really both of these models were given a
chance and it doesn't need to be
antagonistic you yourself could be that
critic right you're evaluating a bunch
of models you want to enter the bake-off
you have every incentive to really and
truly pick the best model in that case
you should explore wide ranges of hyper
parameters so that you can give the best
entry given the things you're exploring
so I'm encouraging you to do this
another nice thing I'll say about this
is if you use the code to do this search
then you can set up a grid of hyper
parameters that you want to explore
click run and then go to the movies or
take a hike and know that that entire
time you are working hard exploring
finding the best possible model that's a
reason for automating this stuff what I
want to talk with you about later
especially in the context of your
projects is bringing some perspective to
this really we're talking about infinite
spaces of hyper parameters and you could
spend infinite dollars doing these
explorations someone has to impose a
budget on you and I think we can have a
discussion about how best to think about
those
Oh Terry constraints for you know
Apriori constraining your search space
and convincing reviewers that you
haven't done anything harmful but for
now I think it's okay I think what we
just want to enable you to do is some
exploration of pretty reasonable spaces
of parameters for your models and that's
what this is all about so again this is
a complete experimental set up what I've
done is leave Phi alone it's just the
bag-of-words classifier representation
but fit softmax with cross-validation
here you start to see the value of
having put wrappers around all these
models as opposed to just calling fit
because what I do in this case is first
set up a logistic regression model I
decide that I want to cross validate
over five folds that see B equals five
and then the really interesting thing is
this what in Psych it is called this /
am great so it's saying for the
intercept bias I'm going to try the
model with and without for this value C
which is the inverse regularization
strength for the l4 oh yeah the inverse
regularization strength I'm going to
explore this range of values from 0.4 to
3 and I'm also going to explore which
kind of regularization I'd do if I pick
l1 I'm probably going to get a model
that favors really sparse feature
representations a lot of the values for
the weights will go to 0 whereas l2 will
give me more nonzero weights kind of
evened out
so I'll explore that as well and then
I've included in the software for the
course in utils fit classifier with
cross-validation you give it your data
set X Y your base mod and your per am
great and the CV value and it will find
for you via cross-validation so it
should be pretty responsible the best
model and then you return that and
that's so if you by default here it's
exploring the full grid of values so
these spaces grow very quickly that's
why you might want to pick a long movie
or a long hike if you've picked a large
/ m grid but the point is that your
model will turn away at this and it will
return what in a data-driven way
has decided is the best model and then
you could enter that into the bake-off
or into a subsequent evaluation yeah
every combination so it does true point
for l1 true point six l1 like that for
all of the values that's what it's doing
it's called grid search
I've hardwired grid search in it's
perfectly reasonable to think about
things like random sampling from the
space I think that typically performs
basically as well and then there are
more sophisticated packages like psych
it optimize that we'll try to do more
data-driven model-based exploration of
the parameter space but all these things
come down to the same intuition which is
explore wide under some budgetary
constraints and this function here best
mod I think it actually prints at oh
sorry yeah when you call that it prints
out the best parameters you'll get some
feedback but you also get the model
itself which you can use subsequently in
terms of SSD experiment nothing changes
and the reason nothing changes is
because all of that cross validation
stuff was packed into this model wrapper
make sense all right so go forth and
explore widely let your computer run
overnight or something like that
second methodological thing that I
thought I would introduce now is
classify or comparison let me set this
up again thinking about interacting in
the community so suppose you've assessed
a baseline model B and your favorite
model m and your chosen assessment
metric favors M so good news right it
looks like you won but is your model M
really better that's a deep question so
first of all if the difference between B
and M is clearly of practical
significance like your model is going to
save lives and you can show it's going
to save a thousand lives then maybe you
don't need to do a subsequent round of
likes it's a statistical compare
or anything right because maybe it's
just clear that we should pick your
model but still especially in this age
of deep learning you have to ask the
subsequent question of whether or not
there's variation in how either of those
two models performs because maybe on one
run
you saved a thousand lives and in
another actually your baseline model was
was saving more so even in the case of
practical significance you want to do
might want to do something further now
I've offered two methods for doing
something further the first is to run a
wilcoxon signed-rank test this is just
wisdom that I got from the literature
that's a kind of nonparametric version
of the t-test that's not assuming
anything about the distribution of your
scores and is allowing you to assess
based on repeated runs of a model which
one is likely to be better and we can
talk later about the rationale precisely
for choosing that test but I guess the
bottom line for here is that it's going
to be a pretty conservative statistical
test that will probably especially if
you can afford to run the model a lot
give you a pretty robust picture of
whether or not your model is truly
better than another one that's really
good the only downside there is you have
to be in a situation in which you can
repeated the assess your two models B
and M so your data set has to support
that like a lot of random train test
splits and also your budget has to
support that right if it takes you a
month to optimize B and M then you're
probably not going to be able to do this
kind of testing because you maybe can
only afford to do one or two runs and
really what you want to have done is
like 10 to 20 runs in those situations
my offer to you is McNee Mars test so
this is applicable in a situation in
which you can just run the models once
you get a single confusion matrix from
them the models and it's essentially
operating just on that fixed set of
values and the null hypothesis that
you're testing there is basically do the
two have the same error rate so this is
noisier and you might have less
confidence in it but I think it's better
than nothing when it comes
to comparing classifiers it's certainly
better than just looking at the raw
numerical values and deciding that the
larger one is clearly superior that
makes sense and again if you think about
reviewers reviewers when they see just
two numbers they want context they want
to know well how big is that difference
really right and you know practical
significance is the best answer to give
but then these things will further
substantiate and in situations in which
the values look small you might still
have a good argument in favor of your
model if the two models are very
consistent in their behavior and then
you could use these tests to
substantiate that even in this face of
what might look like a small difference
and I hope I've made that easy so just
to set that up here at what I've done is
you know fixed bag-of-words feature
representation file like before but now
I have to model wrappers one I've called
fit soft max you might call it fit
logistic regression and the other is fit
naive Bayes this is a classic kind of
comparison especially for sentiment like
let's see which is better logistic
regression or naive Bayes so you set up
those two model wrappers and then the
two ways you can do this are first again
this is a kind of Swiss Army knife SST
compare models you give it at least one
feature function and if you give only
one it will assume that it should use
both for both experiments and at least
one train function here you can see I've
filled that out with fits off max and
fit naive Bayes the rest of the things
are just default values that you can
probably leave alone and it will run all
the comparisons that it needs to to run
the signed-rank test which is given here
as stats test and what you get out is
the two means for the models this is
just printed and a p-value and up here
you can see I'm also returning the full
vector of scores in case you want to
like plot them to get further
information beyond just the means about
how these two systems compare one might
you know have chaotic performance that
you see when you look at the scores and
another might be more rational
and then the other test kind of simpler
to run here I've just run two fixed
experiments softmax and naivebayes
and then you can run the McNee mars test
and here you just have to make sure that
you've run them on the same data and
this is the interface here I just get
the actual values from one or one of the
other of these because they're meant to
be the same and then look at the
predictions so again this will take a
while to run because you have to run a
lot of experiments and this requires
running just one experiment questions
about that all right those are the two
methods things that I wanted to do let's
dive into this feature representation
stuff then I'm just doing this by way of
example and the idea is that you see
having seen a few examples the ways that
you can start to get creative about how
you represent features so so far what
we've done is bag-of-words
it's kind of small but what I've done
here is just do bag of by grams and you
could do try grams and so forth that's
pretty standard oh it's worth trying out
an interesting thing that you can do
because we have tree structures is
actually use that structure and so what
I've called that down here is five
phrases and what it does is represent
the data as all the words that occur in
isolation and all the pairs of words
that occur as siblings of the same
parent on the assumption that it's
interesting that is amazing form a
phrase linguistically but NL Ewan is do
not and you can see the difference is
here so NL u and is for example is part
of the by grams but it is not part of
this phrasal representation because
there's no single parent that dominates
NLU in is and if you play that out over
the very rich tree structures that are
in the SST you find that you're getting
very different representations than you
get from a simple linear pass like by
grams is doing and you can see down here
I've just said the height is
less than three to get just these local
trees but you could set it higher right
and that would be a version of like
getting higher level engrams because
you'd be finding larger and larger
chunks of these trees the other class
that I want to highlight here is
negation so last class I highlighted a
heuristic method that I think is very
powerful of just finding negation words
that are in a lexicon and then marking
them although following tokens with
underscore neg to kind of indicate that
they are in the scope in some sense of
that negation word the problem with that
is that that can be pretty imprecise you
end up depending on things like
punctuation and if the punctuation isn't
there then this negging destrun Zahn and
on way past what you would think of as
any kind of semantic scope for the
negation because we have tree structures
we can be much more precise about this
so like in this example the dialogue
wasn't very good but the acting was
amazing it seems clear that the negation
is meant to target only very good that's
hard for us to keep track of in the
linear method but it's easy with the
tree structure because basically what
you want to do is write a feature
function that when it finds a negation
goes to the parent and then marks
everything that's that's below that
parent and that's very close to what
linguists think of as the scope of the
operator and that's nice because then
all this clearly under gated stuff is
left alone and that's a very general
idea there are lots of things in
language that take scope in this way
that have semantic influences over the
things that are next to them in the tree
so we actually we touched on this last
time they said it was great is not a
speaker commitment to it being great
whatever it is because of this verb of
saying and so you can imagine writing
feature functions that are also marking
things that are in the scope of verbs
like say and claim and maybe doubt and
deny marking them in some special way so
that they could get treated differently
by your model and here I did another one
it might be successful right that's a
kind of hedge
very different from it is successful and
you could capture that by doing some of
this scope marking from might down into
the thing that's next to it and this is
something that's really possible but
only because we have these trees and
here are a few other ideas so obviously
lexicon derive features you're gonna do
some of those for homework one you could
also think about modal adverbs marking
their scope like it it is quite possibly
a masterpiece or it is totally amazing
those adverbs are doing something
special to commitment another idea of
what in the literature is called forded
expectations this is the case where I
build up what seems to be one kind of
evaluation only to offer really another
one right many consider the movie
bewildering boring slow moving or
annoying that speaker might be building
up to a positive endorsement because of
this shift in perspective they're
performing and one signal of that is
that they're kind of laying it on thick
with all of this negative language it
could happen in both directions it was
hailed as a brilliant unprecedented
artistic achievement worthy of must
multiple Oscars but it was terrible
right that kind of review is one that
your model is going to struggle with
because of all the indicators of
positivity balanced by that one word
that was negative but the imbalance
actually might be a signal to your model
that somebody is keying into this
thwarted expectation thing so you could
just count all these words essentially
and look at their ratios and then even
harder of course kind of like the holy
grail for twerkin sentiment analysis is
getting a really good grip on non
literal language use like if someone
says it's not exactly a masterpiece it's
probably terrible if they say it's fifty
hours long for a movie that's hyperbole
they probably don't literally mean it
and they're doing something special
socially or emotionally when they pick
that hyper hyperbolic expression right
or the best movie in the history of the
universe that one is hyperbole and you
feel like it could go either way in
terms of whether it's positive or
sarcastic
and there are lots of other ideas this
is just a sample of them and that
lexicon idea I showed you some lexicons
before that's a pretty rich set of
resources to mine for doing sentiment
analysis oh I had one other
methodological note that I thought I
would insert here because it might be
that for the bake-off for example you
end up writing a lot of feature
functions a bet that you could make
early on for example in this bake-off is
that you should be using linear models
not deep learning models because you
only have till Monday and it can take a
long time for deep learning models to
work and so that might set you on the
path of writing a lot of interesting
feature functions of the sort I've just
been describing to you and I thought I
would insert here just a methodological
note about assessing those feature
functions so you suppose you've written
a lot of them and you might want to be
combining them into a single model which
I'd also encourage scikit-learn offers
in its feature selection package a bunch
of methods for doing for assessing
feature functions individually and you
can sort of what you're doing with those
tools is assessing essentially in
isolation how much information they tell
you about the class label and that could
give you a picture of how much
predictive value they have what I've
done here with this little data set
which I constructed artificially is just
try to send you a warning that assessing
these feature functions in isolation
might be a kind of good first passed
heuristic but it can be very dangerous
because what you end up doing in the
presence of correlated features is often
overstating the value of those features
because what you're really doing when
you run your model is assessing them all
in the context I think a unified model
and that's doing something very
different than you're doing with this
individual testing and I'll let you
think about this example here but the
point is if I use this chi-squared test
in isolation it looks like at least
these two features x1 and x2 are really
good to include and maybe you decide to
drop x3 but the truth of the matter
is if you fit an integrated model then
x1 alone is the best model and including
x2 actually degrades the performance of
the model and so that's argues I think
for something more like a holistic
assessment where you're maybe dropping
or adding individual features but always
in the context of the full system that
you're evaluating and not so much in
isolation the way I've done here oh yeah
something like simple we can do like
maybe some PCA things to understand how
your teachers before you like actually
choose which one is it I think it's a
reasonable response it's certainly a way
removing those correlations it can pull
some problems at test times if you pick
one of those matrix factorization
methods and do that to your train
features if I give you new examples you
have to be able to do that reliably on
those new examples as well and that can
be problematic because the
characteristics of those new test
examples might be very different from
the training examples which is something
to think about in terms of a real
deployment yeah because if you do that
reduction on your training set let's say
you've done that and I give you a single
test example it might be not so clear
what you're supposed to do with that
test example in terms of reweighed in it
re rating its feature values there are
some like psych it actually tries to
manage this so for example I'm not sure
what it does for PCA but if you run TF
idea then if you call fit transform it
will do this to your feature matrix it
will reweighed it and then if you run
that with just transform I think it uses
its IDF values that it is stored from
training and it applies those to the new
test cases oh wait I meant like sorry
like I'm communicating what I meant but
like for example construct like a
correlation matrix of agreements between
like your features Neha be labeled
plus to like use that out of the way to
select which Oh
so not as a way to change the
representations but rather just to do
the selection I think it could be a good
heuristic yeah it's certainly telling
you something about the entire matrix
which was what I'm pushing here can see
pretty much ins I think you get finer
grain in information if you can afford
it by just using actually psych it has
these functions like ablation things
that will repeatedly run your model
having added or removed some of the
features and then you can kind of see
their practical significance in the
context of the full model with exactly
the scaling that you're going to be
using for your task final thing about
feature representation that's a kind of
transition into the world of deep
learning what I'm pitching here is using
distributed representations as features
so imagine my simple example from the
SST is the ROC rules you know the rock
is an actor well I can do in this case
is just look up all of these words in an
embedding space maybe glove maybe it's
when you built yourself right from the
first unit so look them all up what I
need to do in this space is find a way
to combine them into a single fixed
dimensional representation because all
these methods presuppose that all the
examples are coming from the same
embedding space essentially so in this
simple mode what you would do is combine
them you could use for example the sum
of the values component wise or the mean
or the product or whatever some function
that will take them together into a
single representation and then that
function X here is just the input to
your classifier whereas before if we
built a bunch of feature functions like
the bag of words one your feature
representations will have you know like
twenty thousand dimensions and will be
very sparse these distributed
representations of your data will have
50 to 300 dimensions depending on what
vectors you downloaded or built and they
will be very dense
of course right all the vectors will be
active so it's a very different
perspective on your data but it's
amazing how much how well these
classifiers can perform given how little
information you seem to be feeding them
and also how hard this combination step
typically is because of course this is a
hyper parameter to your model it's not
something that your model is learning
yeah if you had eight paragraphs what
would be your limit for how many
pre-trained vectors you would add
together before you couldn't really get
a signal out of that data I said I think
it's actually striking how you could do
this with fairly long documents just sum
them up and get a pretty good
representation of what's in there and in
that situation my intuition is that you
would not want the mean but rather
something the sum that was encoding a
lot of information about the length of
the text which you'd essentially get
from the magnitude of the dimensions as
you added them together but it's kind of
amazing how well that can work as a kind
of all-purpose rough look at the full
text in terms of running experiments for
this again I claim it's really easy Oh
question in the back yeah go ahead this
is a nice baseline for a sequential
model if I wanted to argue for an RNN
that used glove inputs I might use this
as my baseline because what I would be
doing there is saying keeping constant
the amount of lexical information that
I'm introducing what precisely is the
value of modeling the full sequence and
then you'd be assessing your RNN about
how well it did over and above this
simple combination function because it's
kind of like the simplest version is sum
to combine these vectors and the
complicated version is your fancy lsdm
the framework can accommodate these
representations I've given you the full
recipe here and most of this is just
building up the embedding space
love look up I have a general-purpose
feature function that has too many
arguments for the framework so that I
define the special-purpose one that
builds my glove representations soft
Max's as before no change there and then
you call the experiment and the only
thing you have to remember if you have
this kind of data coming in that is
vectors and not dictionaries is to say
vectorize equals false otherwise it's
going to assume that those vectors
coming in are actually dictionaries and
it will do if it does anything at all it
will be something quite crazy what
you're essentially doing here is saying
hey SSD experiment don't feature as my
data form you're using a dict vectorizer
just take it as it comes and then it all
works out other questions about that
approach great let's do two more things
and this is a foray into deep learning
so the first one will be RNN classifiers
this is implemented in a few ways in the
package if you want all the details go
to NPR and then classifier it gives you
the forward algorithm and also the back
prop for learning but I'd actually
recommend that you use what's called
torch classifier RNN or the tensorflow
version because they're faster and more
robust but all of them are drawing on
the same basic structure which I've
depicted here so though ROC rules is my
example I look them up in some embedding
space which could be pre trained when
you built yourself or glove or it could
be a random embedding and then the
crucial thing is the action of this RNN
so it has this hidden layer here and you
do combinations to get hidden States at
each time step and then in the simplest
version the final time step is the basis
for your classification decision so
imagine that by the time I've gotten to
h3 I'm looking at some fixed dimensional
dense representation and that's the
input to a classifier this little part
here is essentially this where X is the
final hidden representation from the RNN
and that's why I think these are kind of
a natural pair if you think about
assessment and so this is just the label
for the SST sequence and these are the
leaves people might have seen these
models before it's worth noting one
thing about how you do pre-processing
that makes these a little bit fiddly so
your examples here are presumably lists
of strings here I've got this tiny
vocabulary so imagine these are all just
different words two examples in the
standard pre-processing flow you map
those into indices and those indices are
into an embedding space that you've
built by default the code will randomly
initialize one of these embedding spaces
but if you feed in your own space it
will use that as the embedding and so
from these indices you do all the
lookups and what the model actually
processes of course is essentially a
list of vectors and so the final version
of these examples is this list of
vectors down here that's the way this is
a kind of standard set up for these
problems it's not obligatory of course
and when we look later in the course at
contextual word representations we will
skip all these things and just directly
look up entire sequences because the
point there is that words could have
different initial representations
depending on the context they're in
which is something that this embedding
lookup thing of course can't capture but
the RNN itself is an exciting
development to my mind because even if I
have fixed representations down here
because I'm modeling the full sequence
like this I'm modeling all of these
words in the context that they occur in
so for example one thing I really like
about this as a linguist is I have an
intuition that negation is important for
sentiment I showed you a messy heuristic
method based on the tokens and then I
showed you a very precise version that
depended on trees but you know the trees
might be wrong or my eye might just be
confused about how scope works in my
data set so both of those have drawbacks
because neither of them is really
responding to information from my
labeled data set this RNN here of course
this sequence of hidden representations
you know one in the same token at point
h2 could be different depending on
whether or not h1 is the origin for n
negation and that's the sense in which
these models just out of the box are
allowing you to have the power to see
those semantic influences play out at
the level of the sequence and the same
thing for might and for say and for
claim and for no one and for everyone
all these things are affecting the
semantic context and therefore affecting
the hidden representations associated
with the words in the sequence so it's a
lovely holistic analysis of your example
with clearly the potential to capture
lots of interesting semantic influences
and I think that's borne out these are
very successful and powerful models for
lots of different tasks I have a note
here on LST m/s I'm not going to dive
into this too much suffice it to say
that regular are n ends like that NP one
down here they struggle with long
sequences and it's not a surprise that
they do because the signal they get from
the training label up here becomes very
diffuse and problematic as these
sequences get longer so LST M's and
other mechanisms like them are ways of
managing that flow of information in a
way that leads to better results and so
the the torch and tensorflow are n ends
both have lsdm cells by default and I'm
not going to give you an explanation of
them here we don't have that much time
and also frankly I feel like I just
can't improve on these two blog blog
posts especially this first one if you
want an intro to LST MS I highly
recommend it it uses a lovely kind of
visual language for helping you think
about what's happening inside these
cells and why they work so well yeah
very helpful and then finally here's a
code snippet to round this out again
I hear I'm building a glove space for my
embedding for the feature functions of
course they get kind of trivialized
because what I want to do is just return
the sequence of words that are the
leaves so I just do that no feature is a
ssin at that point because the real
action is inside fit RNN I decide on the
Train vocabulary and I've decided that
I'm going to keep just the top ten
thousand words by frequency and all
other words will be mapped to UNK you
can set that parameter however you want
up here and then I create a little
embedding space and feed that in here
and there's lots of other parameters
that you can fiddle around with fit that
model to the XY pair that come in and
from there it's just SS T experiment as
usual and again remember to save
vectorize equals false for these models
so that it doesn't assume it's a bunch
of count dictionaries I'm not sure that
would even work in this context and in
terms of hyper parameter exploration
you're seeing a glimpse of it here
there's a lot of values that you could
explore and maybe the dark side of deep
learning is that these things will
matter a lot to the final performance of
your model let me do one more thing and
then why don't we just do some coding
and here in the room and that's these
tree structured networks so it's a it's
a very similar idea to the RNN except
instead of having simple sequences we're
going to process the SST trees as they
come so I have that same example the
rock rules and you have some hidden
parameters in here that are forming
hidden representations here in orange
it's just that instead of processing
them input to hidden and then hidden to
hidden you take the child nodes and
process them together to form the hidden
representation and you do that part
recursively until you reach the root of
the tree which is a hidden
representation and that's the basis for
your classifier and from there it's kind
of
here in my code softmax classifier as
usual and then the back prop is a
process of taking the errors and feeding
them down and splitting the gradients
apart and then feeding them down like
that and you can see true in NP tree and
n exactly how that process works so my
code is a great question my code is just
concatenate the child nodes and feeding
them through this kind of simple
classifier here where you have learned
weights and a bias I think that's a good
baseline for this space it's the first
one that was explored and the first one
that everyone kind of sets up and I've
mapped out three alternatives all these
were explored by Richard Souter
matrix-vector where you represent each
word as both a vector and a matrix and
when you do that combination to form the
parent you kind of cross the matrix and
the vector so that you get lots of
multiplicative interactions very
powerful I think it was too powerful in
the sense that it had too many
parameters relative to the data and
that's how so true at all motivated this
tensor combination here which takes this
combination function and extends it with
essentially a method for combining in
every conceivable way the concatenation
of the two child nodes with a higher
order tensor kind of sandwiched in the
middle allowing for all those
interactions and then you essentially
add that to a function that looks like
this so that's very powerful and
successful and like when I was showing
you examples from the SST project before
that was a model that was using this
combination function and then just to
round it out as a more recent
development in ty at all they have the
feature so the nodes the cut that are
doing the combination functions at the
nodes are LST MS and the innovation
there is that they're kind of gathering
state and other kind of gating
information from the child the two child
nodes separately so that they can be
gated separately
and then combining them into a single
representation and I highly recommend
all these papers if you're interested in
this space this is a nice progression of
ideas and then the final thing that you
could say that unfortunately we don't
get to explore too much in here is that
recall of course that in the SST you
actually get supervision not just at the
tree node the way this model isn't
flying but also in all of the sub nodes
and I have included a model
implementation in our class repo that
will do that and I think the guiding
intuition here is that I have all these
points of supervision on shared
parameters for this classifier so I can
gather them all together and get lost
information for all of them and then
pass that down at each one of the
sub-trees
so in terms of implementation once you
get your head around how all this
information needs to be passed around in
the tree it's pretty straightforward and
then of course you can get really
powerful models coming from the fact
that you're getting so much more
information about what all the sub
constituents mean in terms of sentiment
and then just to round this out this is
a full picture of how you use SST
experiment with these tree models and I
think the only special thing about this
is that the tree models are unusual in
assuming that their label is part of the
training instance itself so in the
default the the regular tree NN it looks
to the root node to find its label as
opposed to having it in a separate
vector and so that's a little bit funny
down here that mod dot fit takes only X
and not Y Y is just there for assessment
its operating on X and the reason for
that is that then in the context of sub
tree supervision I can just gather all
all those points of supervision for my
training instance and not worry about
how they align with some other vector
well I think that's the only gotcha
other than that you can use this
framework for the full set of models
that I've introduced here are there
questions
this is good it gives us some time what
we're imagining for the homework of
course let me just run through it
quickly to get you oriented and then you
can start coding on your own so
sentiment words alone is just asking you
to use a lexicon to create a filtered
bag of words feature function just to
see how much information about the class
label is encoded in this off-the-shelf
lexicon and so what I'm asking you to do
is design that feature function and then
use the McNee Mar test to compare them
just to expose you to that interface and
get you thinking about classifier
comparison so I think that's pretty
straightforward a more powerful vector
summing baseline is asking you to
explore in a little bit more detail that
distributed representation approach that
I showed you as the final phase of
thinking about like linear classifiers
and you're just sort of seeing whether
with a more powerful model than just a
linear classifier one that might uncover
lots of interactions among the future
dimensions seeing whether you could do
better at the problem and then the final
one is your custom system and custom
here just means basically anything goes
it's okay to download other people's
code of course I have a huge bias for
you taking code that we've provided and
doing cool modifications to it to see
whether they pay off but we don't have
to place too many rules here for
designing your original system and
that's what you'll enter into the
bake-off we're evaluating on the ternary
class problem for all of this stuff so
you should kind of hillclimb on that
what you should do is probably do a lot
of testing just within your training
data and periodically test against your
dev set to get a more honest look at how
you're actually generalizing to new data
and never look at the test set of course
the test set although it's distributed
is completely out of bounds until the
bake-off starts and then will actually
run the evaluation and I'll give you
some code to guide you examine exactly
how to do that but have in mind that you
want a system that does well on the
ternary class problem on the test set
and the only other thing that I want to
note is that I added maybe it hasn't
reloaded here I just added a note at the
bottom here asking you to give an
informal description of your system just
to help the teaching team kind of get
oriented on what your code actually does
and what your solution is like so that
we can classify the solutions and come
to some kind of understanding of what
worked and what didn't yeah that's the
plan I mean we hope to give you really
rich reports on this we're aiming to
have the first one on Monday and I can
tell from the submissions that have come
in that there will be interesting
lessons that we can reflect back to you
about what worked and what didn't and
I'm hoping that continues yeah okay I'm
gonna stop talking about it you all just
get coding and we're here to help